hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round 8 of the 2019
Tata Steel chess tournament it's again
between Vishwanathan Anand and Charlie
are mamedyarov
now mama Terra has been having an
excellent tournament he did have that
fluke against Magnus Carlsen where well
he just wandered in the end game we I
guess he just relaxed a bit too fast and
that caused him to you know fall down on
the leaderboard but here he faces a
Vishwanath on Anand and like I said it's
a wonderful game and I don't want to
give away anything as you say you don't
like spoilers so let's just dive
straight into it
Anand opens up with efore he has the
white pieces we have c6 the caro-kann
defense d4 d5 and here we have e 5 Allen
goes for the advanced variation and here
now you have a couple of options
if black feels like really going into a
fight he could go in Bishop f5 and allow
the attack of the bayonets g4
but mama Dee olive isn't up for that
kind of a fight rather he plays c5 and
c5 is one of the moves I really hate and
why I never played the advanced
variation against any sort of c6 d 5 it
basically transposes it into the French
being a tempo a tempo down for black for
example if c36 you just have a normal
French were black lost a tempo with that
first C 6 and then c5 but here armed
decides to go for D captures on c5 as he
prepared something very nice for Mama dr
of e6000 and now they're developing a
piece by capturing a pawn but rope
captures on c5 and now a3 a move that
will come in very handy later when Anand
executes his well novelty Knight to e7
and here we have Bishop to d3 and for
those of you who are perhaps new to
chess you want to remember if you're
playing against the French and black
castles here always remember that if
there's a knight on e7 blocking the
Queen's control of g5 then you can
always go for this well almost always
Bishop captures on h7 sacrifice where
after King captures you can go Knight G
checks King moves and then after Queen
h5 it's game over for black and on the
other hand if after 95 black
sites to go here then after h4 it will
be just a terrible game for black it's
you you can just cross black easily but
ok for those of you who are not new to
chess
Knight to g6 was played I'm not allowing
any such ideas we have castles by Anand
castles by Mahmud Europe and here Knight
B to d2 and ok Mamiya also develops
Knight to c6 here pressuring the e5 pawn
and here Ireland execute his novelty the
reason I say in novelty is because he
plays before attacking the bishop
forcing the bishop to decide whether we
want to go to be six maybe seven Mahmud
arrow goes be six and it's very
interesting in 2018 Greenwich s festival
island headed this position with the
black pieces against Nikita with you go
and here with you go continued with
Bishop to b2 but he Ronon prepares
something else here Ireland plays Bishop
captures on g6 and this is a new move
one of the reasons why I use this quote
by Hammond himself for every door the
computers have closed they have opened a
new one and this is indeed a new move
never played before and it's and it's an
odd move this Bishop on d3 it's usually
White's best piece it usually black
always has to keep an eye on this H bone
if this you know leave its ideas like a
bunch of characters in each zone or
possible but it's just an amazing piece
so it's very odd
giving up the bishop pair in this
fashion you can capture with the H bone
or wood the F pawn both of both
characters seem good for black but it
leads to a different game here mama
Daryl decides to go F captures on g6 and
surely this is the first time a meteor
has faced this or perhaps he is so into
preparation of this opening that he even
has a response prepared for this even
though it was never played before but I
don't have the x on the clock so I have
no recollection
well not recollection as I never even
knew but I don't know how much time
Amador spent on this capture if any of
you do do share and I will either heart
it or what not now but okay Knight to b3
taking control of the d4 square also
maybe
the c5 can be used as an outpost for
tonight we have Bishop to d7 Mamedov
continues developing and now look do you
want okay everything is fine it's a it's
a new game and both of them are now
maybe on a not so much but on an unknown
territory we have a five Mahmud Yara
really wants to open up the position but
a nun closes that we have b5 Knight to
e7 and now a5 and now you see that even
though Anand gave up his Bishop repair
he gave up his very strong light square
Bishop from b3 with this excellent plan
the Queen side he basically made my
maduro's light square Bishop into a pawn
so until my mural can untangle here it
will be very difficult for him to play
this but on the other hand this open
semi-open F file is a lot of problems
for on and so on and has to deal with it
we have looked to see it and now Bishop
to e3 of course you cannot allow this
worship to stay strong Bishop captures
we have rook captures and now Knight to
f5 look of course moves we have looked
at e3 and now g5 as the pawns are
doubled here there's really no use in
keeping both of them you won't push g4
as soon as possible and make use of your
weakness in the position we have h3
Anand prevents pushing g4 and here it's
the critical moment of the game already
I move nineteen Mahmud are here played
b6 and b6 is here is a bad move but it's
impossible to know why it's a bad move
was the refutation of b6 found over the
border by Ireland or was it like the
quote says a new door that was opened by
the computers it's hard to say but it's
really really an amazing idea so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this idea even though it will not
be right away clear why b6 is a blunder
but not so much a blunder but it just
allows White's too much and after I show
you again we're gonna cover y b6 it was
a bad move but yeah feel free to pause
the video here and try to utilize this
position health to the maximum for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are true
an amazing player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
Alan's weakest point in his position is
the backward seat upon which is a
weakness you can't push it to c4 c4 is
covered and well it will always be a
weakness black leader creates some sort
of a rook queen battery or perhaps even
double rooks on the C file who knows and
try to attack this weakness but here
Anand is actually able to place c4 and
what's the idea behind it well of course
if you capture here that's a
impossibility because of rook captures
here you lose the piece the Queen has to
move and then you're just winning on the
other hand if you play something like
for example rook captures on c4 this was
played in the game but now we will see
why it's not possible roof captures on
d5 this was an ins idea and now if pawn
captures Queen captures with check King
has to move and now Queen captures on c4
leaving white with a wonderful position
this Knight can come to d4 you can put
this pawn to e6 it's just wonderful
so after Luke after Sun d5 we have
looked to f7 deciding that the Queen
will not be able to come to d5 in the
future with Czech and also the rook is
now guarding the bishop as the bishop is
attacked twice we are the we are the
rook and the Queen
we have rode back to d3 now there was
actually the danger of capturing the
rook and now Medea of most likely wanted
to shock
Anand as Anand has already done a
wonderful things in this game and it's
only moved 22 he plays g4 he wants to
start an attack as soon as possible bust
open the position the rook is guarding
the pond but he misses well are very
nice to reply by Anand to say the least
Knight to d2 attacking the rook the rook
has to move and now the Queen is also
guarding the g4 pawn we have looked to
b4 and now H captures on g4 forcing the
Knights to move away Knight to e7 and
now simply Knight to f3 and what do you
play here as black white just one
material blacks pieces are all cramped
up your bishop cannot move there's still
this very powerful battery along the D
file here mama Daryl decided to close it
and act
his knight Knight to d5 and now we have
Knight B to d4 what do you do here there
are a lot of threats here such ideas as
Knight to f5 for example as the pawn
the guards DF 5 square also guards the
knight on d5
we have roped left for gaining more
activity for Mama dr but now comes night
to c2 attacking this rook and it's very
hard for this rope to find any shelter
you could go some like Ruby too but the
idea if Ruby 2 is the same as after the
move of Medea of playing mummy they are
played look to D rook to e4 Ruby to e4
and well again pause the video here and
try to find the Hannon's idea as we've
already mentioned that it's not all that
mysterious anymore
but still I mean 29 moves such as such a
brilliancy yes congratulations as I'm
sure all of you farm littleroot
characters on d5 now you have to capture
or you're just down in material he
captures and if I was played and after
Queen captures on d5 with check it was
in this position that Shahriyar mama dr
of resigned the game so not I start to
say not the greatest tournament for him
but yeah losing the dead game to Carson
in a equal it's the equal position but
it's easy to say it's an equal position
when you know it's an equal position
when he was playing it he thought
everything was just a draw and then on
introducing this new Bishop captures and
g6 such a such a fresh idea definitely
not going easy on mommy t harv buddy on
he resigned because after the king moves
you can go rook to d1 there's no way to
to save the bishop here you can for
example just move the Queen but then
Queen captures and you still cannot
capture the night here because of the
checkmate your back rank is weak so
after Queen captures rook captures you
don't have to nice for a rook but still
you cannot capture anything yet still
there are threats of checkmate so let's
say h6 but now g5 you want to threaten
further checkmating ideas so after King
h7 you can just capture King captures
and now rub d6 check King moves and now
you can even push the pawn you're gonna
grab the base exponent and white is just
winning
on the other hand after Queen captures
on d5 if you block rook f7 you also
guard the bishop here preventing rook a
d1 then simply Queen captures only for
you snatch up the rook and it's all over
so yeah 29 moves are in modern days
twenty-nine movie this is just a just
you know miniature and and what a
miniature at that almost all the pieces
stone the board really really just a
beauty a modern beauty
and I did prepare the standings after
round 8 here they are
as you can see crossing and Anand are
now sharing first place with five and a
half points then they are followed by a
nipple King Lear and onigiri with five
points points as they weren't able to
win their games then Timur a job with
four and a half if we did you jarate
with four young she subdued I would four
and then with three and a half points
vladimir pharaoh save and samuel
Shanklin with three charlie mamedyarov
and richard report with two and a half
points one forest and well it's easy to
say what an unexpected surprise that are
chronic isn't too hard wait but it's
just one tournament
you know nothing nothing to worry about
but yeah it's very interesting you know
cross on and on and sharing first place
now ahead of everyone
but it's muhammad yarrow is who they
have to thank as you know you can play a
brilliant game but your opponent also
has to help and yeah I think it's it's
wonderful how had everyone's always
trolling on and that he's too old that
he should the retire from professional
chess but he always keeps on proving
them wrong and he always keeps on
winning this amazing games so you know
definitely a good date a good time to be
alive for chess sir
now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying my
coverage of the 2019 Tata Steel chess
tournament I would like to thank Anton
Surikov Gordon Goodman I just have a set
a Christopher dick and Katie nuggets for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and a funny
story for those of you who are perhaps
into enemy as I'm not feeling all that
great I decided to check out all the
episodes of one punch man Saitama as
I've never actually seen
I've seen maybe episode or two and I
said okay now I'm not feeling all that
great I'm just gonna watch that and I
finished watching the first season and
then I realized that they never actually
made the second season so I was very
disappointed to see that yeah but yeah I
hope you enjoyed that as well
all right yeah as usual you can check -
on my previous video so your thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon